und genau vor dieser hütte steht jetzt
bild kollege sebastian bringe sebastian
du stehst jetzt also vor der hütte des
waldrandes was kannst du uns über die
behausung sagen erst mal ganz klar es
ist ja wir sehen hier im hintergrund
einen gepflegten eine gepflegte
gartenanlage mit zwei holzhäuschen mit
einem trampolin für die kinder und einen
pool und nur wenige hundert meter weiter
entfernt oben im rat der wald rambow in
einer roten rollen züge aus und zwar
unbemerkt von den ganzen nachbarn hier
die uci ist ein bisschen entgegen
man geht über eine schmale treppe hoch
und dann über einen asphaltierten weg
und wenn man jetzt die bilder sieht dann
kann man natürlich erkennen dass die
polizei da mit einem
spezialeinsatzkommando rhein geboren ist
die fenster sind geborsten sich das
umgekippt die schubladen sind
rausgerissen die beamten haben da
wirklich alles auf links gedreht wo
vorher muss man allerdings sagen ist die
hütte scheinbar sehr wohnlich
eingerichtet gewesen dass besonders
gemütlich gewesen verdienen sind vor den
fenstern die wäsche hängt noch auf einer
leine
es gab es einmal so etwas wie eine
kochstelle ist ein grill kann man
erkennen und holzkohle und durch die
fenster hat man einen malerischen blick
runter ins tal
du hast noch mit dem vermieter der hütte
gesprochen was weiß er über den
schwarzwald hamburg ja gar nichts ist
nämlich lohr er hat uns erzählt die
hütte ist längere zeit unbenutzt gewesen
der zweite hamburg wird das
wahrscheinlich bemerkt haben und hat
sich dann diese behausung zu eigen
gemacht
jetzt geht die suche natürlich immer
noch weiter auf hochtouren was kannst du
beobachten wie geht die polizei momentan
vor
die polizei ist natürlich immer noch mit
massiven einsatzkräften vor ort wir
können immer wieder sehen die
spezialeinsatzkräfte einzelne waldareal
umzingeln und dann teilweise mit
maschinenpistole im anschlag jeden meter
durchforsten es ist natürlich gefährlich
denn der wald rambo hat vier polizei
pistolen erbeutet und man muss davon
ausgehen dass er diese feuerkraft auch
benutzen wird wenn es hart auf hart
kommt und jetzt gerade greift auch der
polizeihubschrauber über uns
ein spezialeinsatzkommando ist gerade
hier den weg in den wald hinauf gefahren
ja
die polizei muss natürlich mit größter
vorsicht agieren wir wissen ja nicht wo
ist der wald rambo versteckt er sich
möglicherweise in einer behausung
das sind alles faktoren die diesen
einsatz zum teil unberechenbar machen